AWS the world's largest collection of
awful web services it was created by
Jeff Bezos in 2006 at his secret volcano
base as a diabolical plan to get
startups addicted to cheap Computing
resources like any good crack dealer
they start you off with a free taste
then pricing scales up exponentially as
you become more dependent by the time
you realize you're locked in it's too
late your business will die from
withdrawals if you try to quit currently
it has exactly 69 420 different services
to choose from each one with its own
stupid name and nonsensical icon summer
acronyms some have numbers some are
planets and some are low-key insults at
their Rivals like redshift it's so
complex that you'll want to get
certified with a PhD before even
attempting to launch a hello world and
be careful because many of the services
are like beta products that haven't been
updated in years but impressively they
all still run like clockwork it feels a
lot like developing in a Haunted
Amusement Park and if they don't have
what you're looking for just call 1-800
Amazon and they'll launch a brand new
service for you the next day because the
customer is always right or if you're
building an awesome open source tool
they will immediately launch a service
for it so you can never ever make any
money from your hard work to get started
go ahead and sign up for an account then
the first thing you'll notice is that
your account was immediately hacked and
you now have 500 ec2 instances mining
coins all over the world
conveniently there's no big red shutdown
button and what you'll have to do is go
and click on each server individually to
manually shut it off meanwhile if you
open up the billing service you'll
notice the amount of money you owe has
broken the CSS because the number is too
large at this point you have two options
you can sign out of the application and
pretend this was all just a bad dream or
you can contact support and beg for
mercy they'll forward your ticket to
Jeff's 500 million dollar sailing yacht
where he decides your fate like emperor
Nero if you get a thumbs down it means
you're now homeless but a thumbs up
means we can explore the UI each team at
AWS gets to design their own UI giving
us a wonderful inconsistent freak Show
of a website you've got some products
using bootstrap 1 others that look like
they were designed on Fiverr and some
that are absolutely beautiful now if you
can't find what you're looking for don't
even try to use the search instead just
go straight to Google or chat EPT in the
words of God's chosen programmer an
idiot buyers complexity a genius admires
Simplicity none of us here are geniuses
and that's why we use AWS this has been
me trashing a technology that has me by
the balls in 100 seconds big mistake in
reality though AWS has revolutionized
the way we think about it infrastructure
it's the most popular Cloud platform for
a reason and without it the barriers to
entry for the average Tech startup would
be much higher and for that it deserves
our respect make sure to also check out
my full breakdown of AWS thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one